it is time to officially recognize
Jerusalem as the capital of Israel while
previous presidents have made this a
major campaign promise they failed to
deliver today I am delivering consistent
with the Jerusalem embassy act I am
also directing the State Department to
begin preparation to move the American
Embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem
president Trump earlier today this is a
huge historical day recognizing
Jerusalem as the true capital of Israel
which it is it's so refreshing we got an
American president actually keeping a
campaign promise and not everyone is
happy with the president's decision
Hamas calling for quote a Day of Rage on
Friday here with reaction to this
historic and Wright announcement
Israel's ambassador to the United States
Ron Dermer so many promise so few
delivered this is the capital of the
great State of Israel one of our closest
allies absolutely it's a it's a historic
decision it's not just the president
since the Jerusalem embassy Act was
signed about 20 years ago it's all the
presidents since the State of Israel was
established there were 12 previous
presidents and none of them actually
recognized Ruslan is Israel's capital
and it's been our capital since 1949 of
the State of Israel it's been the
capital of the Jewish people for 3,000
years probably longer than I don't know
if there's another country that can
boast the capital that's 3000 years old
or another people I should say they can
boast a capital that's 3,000 years old
but there have been 12 previous
presidents and none of them made the
decision that the 13th president and 13
is a very lucky number ah for the Jewish
people and it certainly was today and
the Jewish people in the Jewish state
will be eternally grateful to President
Trump for making this decision this will
go down in history also I for the life
of me don't understand how others have
been so hostile to this little country
Braun I've been with you in Israel
it's the size of New Jersey and the
hostility and the tensions and
surrounded by enemies going back to you
know the the the UN Partition Plan to 67
to 73 to modern-day Hamas a day of rage
that's an average day in the
neighborhood
because they have committed themselves
in their charter for the destruction of
Israel
ya know for Hamas a Day of Rage is not
news they probably have 365 days of the
year to rage against Israel they rage
against our existence as a state their
Charter calls for the murder of Jews
worldwide I don't know if they need
another reason to hate us maybe they'll
call for the murder of Jews around the
universe they hate Israel they want to
destroy us but fortunately we have the
ability to defend ourselves and we also
have a great friend in president Trump
and we deeply appreciate the decision we
made today
we're almost running at a time there is
unique because of the threat of radiant
hegemony in the region there is an
unprecedented alliance emerging that is
Israel the United Emirates Arab Emirates
Jordan Egypt the Saudis how closely now
is we do a chance of an alliance nobody
dreamed up before well I think that
you're right Shawn that people recognize
in the Arab world that Israel is not
their enemy but a potential ally to deal
with these challenges I think President
Trump recognizes that as well and that
affords a historic opportunity for peace
I think what the president has done
right now in this decision has actually
helped us advance peace by starting to
deal with reality and truth in our
region all right ambassador this is a
historic day the right thing to do